hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
are you garbage to show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find if
they grow up classy or if they're
absolute trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here in aunt
tooty's basement
feeling good new year new her she's out
she's walking
she's doing her thing she's meal
prepping her son he got a groove back
the whole nine yards i'm telling you
look out for her down the shortest
summer
she's tightening up
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me uh he's my best pal we're
going into the new year together
uh let me tell you something gang the
next time you're reaching for a best pal
you go ahead and make it a kippy is what
he told me i had to say
we gotta move merchandise to introduce
him we got it on a t-shirt give it up
for kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
uh and also you know the money maker
patreon.com are you garbage and get
bonus episodes of are you garbage
we'll do a live stream at the end of
every month with you guys where you get
to ask us questions we ask you
questions it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved help us pay the bills
that's it we love it and of course a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire who's getting real cozy
over there
yeah in the comments he's hanging up his
own [ __ ] chicago bears
[ __ ] wild card
i'm looking for a career like matt naggy
dude i want to suck ass
and keep my job we didn't talk about
that in a staff meeting that thing's got
to come down
nah [ __ ] that it's so much bigger than i
thought it was going to be online and
i'm about it dude
ladies and gentlemen the pride of the
chicago comedy scene our good pal give
it up for the magic man
t-bone toby mcmullen everybody hey oh
yeah bear down
sure and gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly talented
incredibly special guest here with us
today uh this gentleman got his start as
a battle rapper off the streets of
philadelphia
he is the former king of the dot
champion his battles have over 18
million views online he has gone on to
do
incredible things that's right he's a
major personality over there at barstool
sports but the big question in his mind
today
is he garbage i got a [ __ ]
delasandro's cheesesteak and a birch
beer
tells me 100 he is this kid's got
latchkey kid written
both his parents were working do me a
favor gang give us a nice big round of
applause and i say this genuinely
for the one the only roan everybody
thank you guys so much for having me
this is the first time i've ever been
called a comedian
i'm sweating from my armpits because of
it that's a lot of pressure to put on
somebody
but i'm happy to be out here
he drops into it quick yeah dude i can
code switch
okay like the best of them street radio
when they departed
you probably got two accidents didn't
you jesus big time tell me the story
because i'm not that familiar i'm older
than you guys you're young you're cool
um that's very generous of you and we
were saying well he is 52.
i'll be 45. really 45.
i'll be 45 in february time for a
prostate exam
one at the doctor's this time not to do
it home kid
[Laughter]
shove your thumb up your butt dude
if it's brown and doing it wrong
oh my god but no this is uh this is i i
feel like
a little bit of time coming this is uh
you you've gone through a couple of bar
stool people
but none of that i mean you you had kate
in here kate's philly trash
hates she has that same type of uh
disgusting
delco traction about it
yeah yeah there's something disgusting
about it but i saw you having all these
other trash bags on
and i knew about the philly background
so i was like it's a matter of time
i'm circling around the toilet bowl
about to flush through
just sitting here listening to you
sitting here listening you've definitely
bought or sold weed in an acme parking
lot oh my god big time
just a lot yeah it's a gram it's like a
[ __ ] point
baby
i bought the worst weed in college off a
[ __ ] brick and we used to put it in
or we put orange peels in with it to
fluff it up be like no it's good it's a
citric flame
exactly oh [ __ ] that's what we did
we did that dude everybody has like a
really good bud you would put some
orange peel in there to make it like
special yeah fluffed up i don't know how
there's some kind of [ __ ] magic
properties well they felt like the
liquid would go into it and make it
denser on the scale it was actually
point eight but a red is a gram
it's a [ __ ] this garbage answer i
don't know what it is some magical
properties
it's moisture yeah banana peels going
into the wheat
it rehydrates it rehydrates that's what
it is this wasn't at the university of
pennsylvania i think
it was uh it was west philly penn
state abington no you went there
no no i didn't i don't like kid no i
wasn't talking
i went to maine campus that was a
feather in my hat
that i was up in main campus like you
made the whole family proud if you went
straight to maine
you were gonna be a doctor or something
like everybody gets into
every campus but i wore it around like i
was going to the universe like it was
wharton or something
awesome it was big it was big for sure
but i love it
penn state abington that's [ __ ]
fantastic yeah that's that's
the thing i had my cousin shout out to
my cousin who listens he's from the
north he's lived in the northeast
and went to abington and lived there
like he it was like 12 minutes from his
life
he went to penn state abington and got
like a i was like dude what are you
doing
calling his mom what time is it
i miss you guys are you coming home for
the holiday like no i'm not gonna have
i'm not gonna stay up on campus
septa ain't running can't make it all my
northeast boys went to
holy family holy family holy families
the was that d3 or something like that
they would all get like a scholarship to
holy family it's like you got free meals
i'm pretty sure
you got like a dining cart with your
scholarship you just swiped in the holy
family that's like
i did that at weidner university yeah
and then when i
you know i played football there but i
tell people i got a scholarship which it
really was exactly what you're saying i
got oh you [ __ ] i got
you're in 80 episodes he's been bragging
about his sky he's like gosh i got some
money to play ball
ron called it out you got chicken
fingers that forced me what are you
talking about have your [ __ ]
jersey frame you're in the background
like you did some [ __ ] that's my high
school jersey yeah it was about that
looks like
you also got chicken fingers i had a
full scholarship there
um hell yeah mike a kid who listens that
was going to widen her now hit me up and
was like asking me what the scene was
like
back then it's like two buildings what
are you talking about
i said the cafeteria was awesome back
then what's it like what's it like now
and this is how trashy
at my school is he's like yeah once a
semester they do a crab feast
i only give one ticket out per student
so nobody doubles down
i was like oh man that's some trash dude
if you're playing hard defense at the
crab feast at your college
you know parking lot i thought crab
feasts were like you lay out like a
piece of paper and everyone sits around
a table or something you're just walking
up to the parking lot and getting your
your like little
styrofoam plate oh my god
that's not dude if you're eating
cafeteria cooked crap
that's not something you rolled a dice
switch they're already bottom feeders
like one of the cafeteria ones
how cheap are those these are from last
year
crabs from the bad neighborhoods laying
around
all right so give me the full backstory
because like i said i'm a little older
uh these guys are all huge fans of you
where did you start out where did you
grow up give me the deeds
so delaware county delco but it's like
uh
to be completely honest it's like more
the villanova side than the havertown
side which is points against me on this
no that's what you mean the villanova
side that's the main line that's what
we're saying is what i'm saying that's
classy that's points against me on the
other side if i was like in havertown
the [ __ ] uh drexel hill area or
whatever there would be no question
about
my trash credentials i went to saint
joe's prep
it also doesn't help ice no [ __ ] prep
school you know
that was a big my family's a big saying
they're all like taught there yeah yeah
it is like people who go to st joe's
prep really love to [ __ ] tell you
that they went to saint joe's practice
it's always
there's a lot of that that's always a
thing there's a lot of great private
schools
in the films the public schools suck you
gotta do something
no good public schools at all there's
none at all either
or charter schools charters a ton of
[ __ ] charter schools where people are
just getting education [ __ ] rob from
them
but uh i don't trust the charter school
i don't know what's political here
i thought that's what this was goddamn
cuomo
[ __ ] kenny uh but uh i went to uh
went to st joe's prep uh then i went up
to penn state main campus
had no discernible talents uh whatsoever
but then i started uh battle rapping i
got into the battle rap world in college
in college some uh famous guy came to
college and it was like
i ran into him and pretty much like
after a show in like the backstage area
it was like i heard you rap
and uh we had like a rap battle it made
it on world star hip hop like 10 years
ago so that definitely plays into my
garbage
uh who's the famous guy this guy charles
hamilton remember charles howard he had
a song called brooklyn girls it was like
one he had one good song and then he
battle rap me lost
a brooklyn girl you kind of did you like
ruin his career and he also got punched
in the face by a girl
or something like that he had a he had a
band like oh nine or something never go
to penn state again
it was a terrible 09 for this dude well
also
as uh as a white dude from you know the
surrounding philadelphia suburbs
to you we like your video yes went viral
in our scene they were like did you see
the dude at penn state who battled
charles hamilton
oh so that's how you battle wrapped him
right there after a show after a show
and beat
him yeah and i didn't know it was even
being filmed pops up on worldstar the
next day
and then over the next like couple
months i start getting calls from these
battle rap leagues that are like
come battle rap with us and i didn't
really have illusions of doing it on
like a professional scale
i mean you barely can do it because you
don't get paid [ __ ] like comedy yeah
yeah it is common it's like you're get
but you can like say like more
homophobic slurs like
the only difference you're gonna be a
little bit more you get to say the
f-word
and uh so i wound up like kind of
building up and i got to travel all over
the world like going to like sweden and
like [ __ ] battling dudes from like
the philippines and [ __ ] like that and
like australia
and [ __ ] like that and uh kind of
ascended through the battle rap world
uh like won some championships and that
was enough accolades to get me some
writing jobs
and uh to get my foot in the door at
barstool and so now i'm in a bar stool
and uh you know
uh i guess that that's that's the
history that's the trunk international
sensation yeah right
yeah dude there's a lot of internet
celebrity yeah i love it dude
you did a salad for white dudes from
suburban philadelphia
back in the day we were like yo this
dude exactly but everyone who knew me
was like this dude's a [ __ ] like
he's fooling everybody like i know
you're a [ __ ]
like not the st joe's prep he's a prep
kid i saw you get punched in the mouth
at a frat party and not do anything
about it like
stop trying to tell these dudes you're
gonna like [ __ ] shoot him or
something at a [ __ ] rap battle
you're lying ah that's great
you're lying to us so what's the family
history so
you're going did you go to private
school the entire time what'd your mom
dad do brother sisters all that stuff so
my mom's from chicago she's a bears fan
one of eight from chicago uh and my dad
is from uh new york up here
she's uh he's he grew up in the in the
projects up in new york
okay at uh 104th and columbus in like uh
like a little bit shittier at the time
now it's like basically just uptown
yeah west side it's nice but like near
columbia columbia
yeah right yeah kind of around there it
was uh frederick douglass house was the
name of his project so i'll come up and
hang out with my grandma she lived there
until she died so uh
born poor died poor you know what i mean
but i didn't know it was the projects at
the time i just thought like
all of new york smelled like piss it
does but i just had no idea that there
was
any kind of income related to it uh so
what'd your dad do he he became he a
physicist
he's a [ __ ] uh he's smart dude yeah
smart dude starts out in the projects in
new york city
and became he went to manhattan college
and uh then he went to princeton for
graduate school
smart dudes all right i mean look kind
of foo food how can we get his grandmom
out of the out of the projects
i think i don't think there's like any
cash in physics
you're broke for the most part you gotta
be robert oppenheimer and come up with a
nuke
okay make any kind of cash like you
gotta be selling nukes
imagine hey oppenheimer got his mom out
of the [ __ ] mom you're not gonna
believe
what i put together i had to do some
things but uh we're gonna get you out
i had to go some japanese but uh you're
good mom
got your house in long island did you
read the papers today
boy i did that [ __ ] boy
but uh and then my mom was uh my mom's a
nurse
uh yeah my registered nurse registered
nurse right so they settled in the
philadelphia area they they moved into
the philadelphia area they had i have an
older sister
also a physicist she married a physicist
jesus so you could tell that i'm like
you're the black sheep [ __ ] idiot of
the family
well all the physicists are sitting
around with like beakers and they're
like what's wrong doing it
he's wrapping some guy uh i swear to new
york dude that really like they'll give
me gifts from for my like for
like christmas that i can't figure out
like board games and [ __ ] like
rubik's cube like oh my god yeah just
abacuses and like
i don't know what to do with any of this
tyson [ __ ] rocket set like what the
[ __ ]
i'm by far the dumbest person in my
family but uh
it manifested itself through me just
being able to hurl insults at people
uh in in the battle rap world like
that's all i had it worked out though
deep self-loathing
that i externalize towards other people
that's most that's most
performers of some kind you know what i
mean yeah you have to hate yourself
so i would have to imagine with a house
full of physicists
uh and and and nurses that you had to
grow up somewhat classy as far as the
structure of the household
what do you mean the structure of the
household as far as like i imagine your
mom ran a tight house the place was
clean
what was it a single family home yeah
it's like uh
yeah out of what is a single family home
connected to other homes
is it a road home we're talking about a
rojo yeah we didn't have
yeah we had neighbors one of them no we
weren't leaning up on other houses we
stood on our own too
but uh we uh
[Laughter]
so many dumb comedians that we have on
think that that's what we mean they're
like no it's just us it's just us it
wasn't anyone like a regular house not a
row home not a connector yeah it was a
regular suburban house
relatively uh a relatively uh
tight ship that they ran around the
house there you go i kind of had i don't
know if i was i wasn't really making my
bed but i went to a phase in my life
where my parents started making me call
them
ma'am and sir because i was getting too
[ __ ] mouthy wow i was being too
flippant
that's like [ __ ] yeah they ma'am insert
my ass and i'll still catch
myself calling my dad sir it's like i
feel like i'm in the [ __ ] military
holy [ __ ] that's the first time we ever
had that a man and a sir
they were just because i think my mom's
[ __ ] mom was like
the strictest woman of all time so okay
a little bit of that must have trickled
down where she was like
you're an [ __ ] like [ __ ] star call
me ma'am and [ __ ] saluting on the way
me sir god damn it that's awesome
what age of about this was when you're
probably about 10 years old or starting
a little rambunctious killing yourself
yeah and now i'm just a sir guy like
i'll just throw around sir to like
whomever i'm talking to i'll tell you i
just dropped whom ever as well i don't
know if you picked up on that pretty
good
that's pretty classy i honestly came
into this with a complex that i wouldn't
be garbage
like i was like worried that [ __ ]
because i want to be i want to be
garbage i want to be accepted by you
guys well you did come here
he came in and threw his jacket on the
ground right under the [ __ ] coat rack
so that was a pretty garbage he walked
in he looked like we were in his [ __ ]
dressing room
he dropped his jacket on i was like
where do i sit jim carrey
where's my close-up you're the first
person to come in here and be like
points against me i want to be garbage
everyone's like i'm not [ __ ] trash
don't you [ __ ] then you're like yeah
the only the only thing we really seek
here is the truth you know what i mean
like you're like garbage not garbage
you're accepted 100
i know there's obviously going to be
elements of garbage yes and it's all but
it's very interesting to see the
dichotomy
of like where people come from and where
they end up or where they
you know or vice versa that you know i
mean you could come from trash you could
end up being classy
you could come from garbage and then you
know the whole the whole nine yards
cause i wind up almost
branding myself as philly garbage like
it's almost like it's helpful for people
to contextualize when they meet me
sure and so imagine them finding out
that i used the word whom yeah exactly
he made it through nine years of battle
rap and then gets caught on this
he's like hillary baldwin
[Laughter]
there's people there's something from
for most people from philadelphia that
it it is just in grant there's a
trashiness ingrained
and the money doesn't matter and it
doesn't matter yes
it's there's just a trashiness ingrained
in people from
the philadelphia area that you can't
shake talking about the sweatpants
yeah a lot of pajamas at home depot and
stuff yeah big time
and the whole world has kind of accepted
sweatpants over like the last like five
years they've made a heavy run
mainstream or whatever but yeah i've
been wearing that [ __ ]
a fifth of my yearly budget goes this
way got my grey russell's on
what were the grades like uh they got
into maine
yeah i got an amazing campus but like it
was like i think i had a
band i was like a 3-1 my uh my freshman
year of high school
and then i got that adderall
prescription and that [ __ ] skyrocketed
i was [ __ ] three nine i think i got a
4-0 one semester
because they're like there's the garbage
right now exactly yeah you gotta
middle-class suburban garbage dude i was
on my pill bottles
right showing up it was an off-brand
adderall called stratera
tarot was big back in the bro they had
me on 80 milligrams a day
i knew the [ __ ] answers before the
test was like administered bro i [ __ ]
had everything
and they were like you need more time on
the test because of this this uh
add and my grades started going up but i
was getting the extra time
i would take the test in class and then
i would clean the entire classroom
i had a [ __ ] toothbrush on the floor
no i would get the answers from
everybody else that i took the test with
and then at the end of the day i would
finish the test but i had the answers
from everybody so i was just like
nice i cheated
it was cheating and taking adderall so
the grades got substantially better
through no fault of my own that's
awesome but fake it till you make it man
yeah
grades got better i graduated with like
a 3-0 from penn state where i graduated
in
journalism and theater that's not bad
three oh but those are the fakest majors
of all time though
journalism is theater pretty good you're
kind of using both of them i mean you
perform
i'm the only one that's using
immediately either of those nobody who
gets a journalism degree is like writing
for a [ __ ] newspaper
nobody wants to reunion yeah i'm alone
standing in a room what was the s.a.t
score high school s.a.t was
it was a 14 30. 16.
it's not freestyle rap okay i'm writing
i did some like freestyle
rapping and like that's okay but like i
write the [ __ ] out beforehand
and memorize it it's like a [ __ ] set
it's like a [ __ ]
tight ass five but i say it only one
time
and i have to get it perfect the first
time it's not like i can recycle any of
the material but it's just
uh planning it out knowing where the
punch lines are gonna be
working on the timing of it by myself or
whatever it's not like it's just this
extemporaneous like connecting word [ __ ]
that uh
i'm doing quickly like in my mind or
anything it's just memorization i didn't
get that one word extraneous
yeah yeah he's zoned out i'm trying too
hard my head almost fell off right there
when you said that
keep it simple he got an 870
by the way shout out to widener what's
up
that's why he got paid in chicken
fingers
the board was like no we can't give this
guy money to come here he got a [ __ ]
just to be clear it is a scholarship but
like rone said they just referred to it
as grants in division three yeah i
didn't have to pay the money back
you didn't have to pay the money back he
wasn't going to even if he did by the
way
no loans no no i had a couple loans a
couple loans
logging around i kept it light i only i
only i only made it two years and i was
out oh [ __ ] yeah
get out of there you don't want to waste
your time and then you got my
associate's and left
oh good you should go back and you
should for the patreon you should go
back and get your college degree
that'll we'll really we'll be making 100
a month
if i go to like penn state or something
like that i'll get into abington my
cousins
i'll say it right now at 1 000 patreon
subscribers we will enroll
foley and devry yeah let's do it okay
let's get it one
i need a small workload
just yeah just
slowly but surely i'm gonna i'm i'm
subscribing for that then
yeah there you go we got one in patreon
slash what what am i are you garbage
are you garbage patreon.com 800 we'll
all take the s.a.t
yeah oh dude let's get a copy of an old
s.a.t
and see if you've improved at all
there's
no chance yes there's no chance there's
no chance it's
give me an sat question if you guys
remember one ballpark
wasn't it like if a train leaves chicago
chicago if a train leaves chicago
at 11 a.m and it's traveling that fast
isn't that it's all critical
who's paying for the ticket it's a
fantastic i don't know he got at 14 30.
what are you looking at i don't know i i
wasn't smoking weed at the time was my
thing like i hadn't
begun to smoke weed at that time so it
just i think it
zapped everything out of me i think that
whatever point in your life you start
smoking weed you just stop growing at
that point i think that your mind
regresses back to whenever you started
smoking weed
that's a that's a pretty solid theory
once you really get heavy into it
uh you just remind yourself why well you
have the mind of the twelve
you're nine years old i was fifteen and
that's so [ __ ] accurate
it progress past that you can't at all
um my buddies i just just remember my
buddy to take the sat he's never taken
adderall before so my buddy's like yeah
just take adderall you're
really [ __ ] focused and he had never
taken i forget how much he took whatever
and dude he came out panicked he just
got like stuck on one question for like
an hour and a half and he's like dude i
only
i only got through three questions just
because he was like hyper focused on the
[ __ ]
three questions and two packs of six
they tried to put me on it for
a half a minute my sophomore year of
college to try to save my college
experience because i was
i was [ __ ] doing acid at the point mr
terry ain't going to stop
but it didn't take me my boys crushed
the whole bottle one weekend new year's
eve
at penn state main campus oh one of the
frat houses yeah i brought it up there
it was [ __ ] gone by the time we came
home oh my god that's it so it wasn't
the time release it wasn't like that
you could crush it up it wasn't like you
didn't have to like take off some kind
of sleeve to be able to snore down
you could you could and we did i have it
on good authority that you can snort the
time really
those are the little balls right yeah
yeah
that's real trashy that you know about
this sleeve
so don't worry yeah my oxy 80 friends
oh got a bunch shout out to vinnie the
skinny my buddy had a prescription for
five milligram adderall that were blue
and when it would be test night you
would know who was on [ __ ] who was
all sped up
because their [ __ ] nose would be blue
it's just they can still just smurf up
their [ __ ]
glow it's like an avatar calm garbage
promo code garbage bluetooth.com holy
[ __ ]
but for the most part growing up a good
kid uh
i was like uh yeah a little cl class
clown-ish i don't think i would uh and
no teacher
ever liked me uh like i got like i
remember like a babysitter like slammed
me up against the wall
like he's an [ __ ] i was like a
[ __ ] female or male
a male a male babysitter
down there he was frustrated probably
yeah
babysitter yeah [ __ ] slam you're
probably [ __ ] making fun of them
with your life anyways go get me
get me a diet coke but uh yeah i was
always a yeah against
uh i i had a problem with authority i
could i think uh between 17 and 18 i got
arrested five times
like a hot streak here we go mostly for
like
underage drinking and stuff like that
and my mom at the time thought that
those were the only five times i had
underage drink it was like it was really
bad
she's like adam has the worst one yeah
it happened again and this is busted at
a party in high school busted at a party
or i'm in a car with people who are
drinking or we're at a phillies game and
we get arrested
it was it was five times in six months
so we had arrested it again
the state troopers were doing it they
were running up they were dressing up
undercover
and they would fdr yeah they would pull
up in philly's gear
yeah they'd get out there like yo you
know go phil's and you're like yeah yeah
all right
and then like the one could do they
rolled up on us and they're like oh
they're like
hey go go philly's like yeah yeah like
you got id we're like yeah [ __ ] that you
know what i mean like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever and he's like no i'm serious
like it's like training day style yeah
yes exactly state troopers thank you
it was dollar dog night too yeah clearly
it was dollar dollar
jam job they get you it's like a stinger
it's bait car
it was they had [ __ ] bait 40s out
there some hurricanes that i [ __ ]
scooped up
it was entrapment they knew because a
bunch of under us a bunch of underage
kids coming from the suburbs like yo
it's dollar dog nights get a case of
beers we'll go in and eat 19 hot dogs
and fall tonight best it's
so you've been arrested at sporting
events yeah it's definitely fun
yeah a couple in a row but i will say
this i used to love
when the cops would come to a high
school party and everybody would run
like this
dude that adrenaline of scattered yes
dude kids in the
kitchen fences never have that feeling
yeah that is the best suburban feeling
ever you're in some nice house
nobody gives a [ __ ] the cops it's like
three cops and what are they going to do
[ __ ] 20 kids bail at the screen door
and one person's getting caught
yeah it's the best down the shore it
happened a couple of times
we had to hop in the bay one time and
weighed up
we waited once we waited up to like the
next house so we like let the current
take us
to a house over as we're leaving we're
worried about princeton and st
joe's prep you're diving into the bay to
[ __ ] avoid the heat
it was and uh we also were like amateur
yeah
[Laughter]
but uh we would also like act like we
knew our rights the cops would come to
the
the like the parties down the shore and
we would just like lock the doors and be
like they can't come in
that was that was big well it was when
jay-z said you need a warrant to check
the glove box of the trunk everybody
thought they were a lawyer right away
that's a generational thing we were we
were still at the point where
the cops said anything you were you you
you listened to them nah we
got you we got we yeah we got a little
we definitely thought we that like if
the cop didn't have his lights on when
you drove by him he couldn't pull you
over that kind of [ __ ]
there's all these myths that's what i
did up here i thought like i came to
visit
fordham and uh they're like dude if you
drink like your beer out of a brown
paper bag like you should be fine and i
was like
strolling through the subway with my
beer in a brown paper bag and the
undercover came up to me and just
ripped the bag and was like you're under
arrest like you're [ __ ] dumb
well that with philly people that's dip
it's just different man
dude billy's still a place you can smoke
on the subway platform like
the last time i was home we were just it
was like [ __ ] 4 p.m we were just
smoking on the subway platform
no one says [ __ ] yeah they don't care
it's literally philly's a [ __ ] rough
spot
man they do not care at all wait i want
to hear the bae story you're you're
running from the cut yeah
what's your point growing up by the way
i didn't go to the shore growing up we
would go out to chicago to hang out with
my grandmom or whatever but uh then in
high school we started going to
i went to uh ocean city for a summer we
had like a little summer house and then
this party was in uh
like stone harbor i think like and to
avalon
beautiful houses out there a lot of
quiche
overhead that was that was that was a
philly scumbag fact of stone harbor
oprah's got a house down here she does
she did she did i would have [ __ ] i
only knew about like the laze guy like
the guy
like that's the oxmage that's the
pretzel rage
they got chip money yeah dude got a
house down here
my boy bobby buds runs a would do double
decker tours in chicago
and he was of course he was just the
plot from the breakup what are you
talking about
you're talking about talking about vince
vaughn and that other wacko yeah yeah
and he would play a game with himself
when he would be able to get drunk on
the tours obviously
and then he would see how many places he
could say oprah owned before
would start being like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] place you said oprah
that's pretty good steve harvey lives
there and there
and
oh man shout out to steve harvey that
would be a big selling point on me for a
short house i don't care where he is
steve harvey could be 20 miles off the
coast hey steve robbie lives here though
i saw steve harvey hanging outside of
trump tower in chicago like what one
time in 2015. i had to like [ __ ]
double take it was like the most
chicago thing that dude yeah he's just
saying dude the saddest thing was that
hair was fake that whole time i couldn't
believe it
that was shocking that was jarring that
because like dudes used to go be like yo
give me the steve harvey lineup you know
what i mean like
unattainable he had that unattainable
[ __ ] what about the mustache though
is the mustache fake tube
that kind of messed up that adhesive
would no way it's all perfect
but it had the same machine though it
had the same glow yeah man he's got a
lot of cash to speak yeah i don't know
what to believe i don't know what to
believe at the end of the day with heart
shout out to harvey man shout out to
harvey you're in the bay
i was in the band and i just dropped it
down it was nice it was night the
[ __ ] cops like rushed in from every
every angle also no stone harbor cops
jumping in the wall oh no
i wouldn't i didn't even know we just
drifted down [ __ ] hopped out of the
water and [ __ ] we're on our way
we just already went to another party
i've escaped the cops more than i've
been arrested by the cops that's pretty
good
he said he's got the seaweed on him
looking like seal team six showed up i
had the ghillie suit
coming out with the [ __ ] no who's got
the cups yeah
he got it right for five bucks
that's a childhood story you can't
[ __ ] yeah true dirtbag
they they chase they would chase more in
stone harbor we ran from the cops one
time there's like a big field outside of
uh like
there's a couple bars that are like face
of field in stone harbor
and cops started chasing us through the
field one time and my buddy like kind of
gave a little head fake to a cop
and it was like a movie the cop fell
into uh
a net a soccer net and got caught in it
like a fish she like shook the [ __ ]
cop
and that guy was just in a [ __ ]
soccer net they did they want him
catching my friend that's the situation
got him though they arrested his ass
yeah and they don't cause they don't
like that [ __ ] they didn't like
humiliate yeah you gotta get away from
it yes exactly
we got so lucky we almost gave ourselves
up we were like maybe 12 or 13 we were
staying
in uh in stone harbor at like somebody's
house and we met these girls
on like the playground at stone harbor
we're like oh we're going to meet here
[ __ ] at like midnight tonight we had
to go through those avalon
dunes and the beaches in avalon just so
people don't know
it's like normandy they're like [ __ ]
yards long man
so we're running through the dunes girls
never show up we're walking back
defeated at like [ __ ] two o'clock in
the morning because it was like at least
a half an hour to get there
we're all sweaty all of a sudden behind
us [ __ ] hits the lights
we just [ __ ] take off through this
neighborhood and it was literally like
he was doing like parallels we were
jumping over
fences and [ __ ] hiding and jumping on
the next street and dude it started to
get real serious like all of a sudden
there was like two of them we could feel
the spotlights like it felt like we were
in [ __ ] boys in the hood
and we were just getting we are in stone
harbor
the richest zip code
they got toby but i thought of myself
like that like once i ran from the cops
once i was like man i have something to
rap about now like
i'm like i'm hardened i'm gonna give
this rapid thing a try i was in like
[ __ ] lacoste and yeah i was like i'm
[ __ ] hardened now
uh dude we were gonna crush crustable
wait before you get home
we were in avalon one night at the
princeton all right that's the big bar
down in avalon and we got i got in a
fight
and i'm all we're all banged up was when
vodka red bulls hit big that time it was
like vodka red bulls
and shopkins got a perfect
[Laughter]
super bad man we get in a fight i get
thrown out cops are like they like
receive me as i get tossed out we're
like oh we're leaving you know what i
mean it was whatever
shirts all ripped i'm like [ __ ] you
know got punched in the mouth i'm like
bloody we
so we're walking home it's me my brother
and my buddy and my buddy and my buddy
falls in a sinkhole
as we're walking home it's in the middle
of the street it was it was like a one
foot by one foot he stepped in and like
towards meniscus he had to get surgery
so he goes he goes to the he's like i'm
going to file a report with the city
because like he didn't have health
insurance or something so they don't
report the city they're gonna have to
pay for this it was a it was a city road
so he goes he goes i need a i need a
witness so he's like
you're gonna have to come with me i'm
like all right i was so banged up
tonight before i didn't really remember
i'm like yeah man let's go
we walk into the [ __ ] police station
like you're the guy who got thrown out
of the bar like three hours ago
we know you you're like dude get out of
here i'm here to file a clean
yes it's pretty bad when i'm your star
witness dude it ain't good yeah my buddy
fell in front of oprah's house
the cops like which one yeah i'll take
my settlement in chips please
all right let's get into a little game
called are you garb this is a hot one
baby
yes we're gonna ask you a series of
questions uh answer them open and
honestly
um i was thinking now i want to know
what your life's like now
where you're at class-wise now um i'm
interested in that you have your own
place you have roommates
i i live with uh my fiancee a little
french word for you
that means that's my dane
that means number one girl for everybody
out there in bristol my
old lady but uh yeah i'm in
uh in vinegar hill so uh brooklyn
uh uh okay nice coaster coasted dumbo
little so that's kind of nice it's kind
of sounds nice vinegar
i like it over there but she moved up
from philly
so it was like uh she's like wasn't
trying she wasn't gonna move up unless
she was like happy with where she was
living right
yeah yeah so she was like right we gotta
she to be able to
feel like comfortable in her
neighborhood what does she do
she's in medical sales medical devices
so she does okay she does okay she does
well for herself
she does well for herself all right um
so yeah we're out we're out in uh
in dumbo uh yeah so
that again like i feel like that's
another strike against that's all right
i'm almost like reticent to admit the
truth about myself
no no i'm not at it i got i got one we
got dirt on you yeah
i mean the bay
[Laughter]
uh god how much tuna tartare you ran
from the cops and dumped in the bag
uh at a family gathering will your
family serve buffalo chicken dip
ooh i don't even think my family knows
about buffalo chicken
couple of egg heads the family seems
real classy
they're not like wise to buffalo chicken
yeah but like uh
i i have begun to demand buffalo
i've grown to love buffalo chicken dip
but like buffalo chicken dip was like
came after rebel and vodka's in my
consciousness like i didn't start
learning about that
was it part of your whole lives no no it
was about a decade ago
it hit a decade post 9 11.
that's how we coped yeah started making
everything into a dip
um yeah the family's going to be tough
the family's going to be tough
but we'll get to the bottom of that one
of them being a [ __ ] some of them
have to be do you ever take the pop quiz
that they have on pawn stars right
before the commercial
dude uh yeah i think i've that's a deep
cut dude it's a deep cut
what channel is pawn stars on discovery
i'm more of a tlc guy
i'm more of a like a little people big
world guy
and a 600 pound life guy like i'm kind
my guilty pleasures thousand pound
sisters is solid too i don't know if
you've seen that see i feel like the
garbage on tlc is a little bit classier
than a and e
no i don't know tlc is horrible you
think so do they have anything better
than storage
they have a thing called thousand pound
sisters i know but they do in kind of an
educational sense but it is barnum and
bailey though like
tlc is just like these are the tallest
[ __ ] in the world
it really is like it's like this woman
has a beard
and it's called the learning channel too
that's what it stands for
but they really took a left somewhere
cultural oddity tonight
check out the weirdos yeah you feel good
about yourself because it says tlc but
you're just looking at like the the most
depraved and like [ __ ] sickest people
you can find
like the weirdest looking people i did
see a commercial for the one that you
were talking about the two sisters
i've said it twice in the past minute
thousand pound sisters yeah that's uh
did you think i was talking about
another show about fat sisters
but i think that they have like six like
fat shows on
uh they're good at the spin-offs you
know what i mean they just crank they
find the formula and start cranking them
and they have a couple little people
shows too they have little people big
world but then they have little family
too they're a whole different set of
little people don't they have one with
little people and pit bulls
do they i know what you're talking about
that might be random people
he ran like a pit bull rescue it was
just one guy he was a little guy there
oh and that guy's little
i would have watched the show if i knew
he was literally i had no idea he's like
a biker he's got like the fedora and the
chains and stuff like that is that
that's pitbulls
and parolees maybe or something like
that i don't know that might be it i
think he does
what we're figuring out is tlc's
wheelhouse is fat people and digits
yeah it really is or little people it
really is
no we have a guy that or yeah i'm not
sure exactly what the specific
nomenclature but our
our guy zaha who works with us he said
he prefers the term [ __ ]
okay yeah i don't know i'm trying to i
would love to be as sensitive as anyone
wants me to be but you know what i mean
i think he wants it i think they go
little people yeah as a whole when
you're getting it fair enough
what's the furthest you've ever drawn
for a drove for a family vacation
oh we drove to iowa [ __ ]
loaded everybody up did you lose a bet
yeah
i think we were like my like aunt was
like adopting somebody and we like just
drove like straight from philly to iowa
we stopped at a a
w roo this is the only thing i remember
there was like an a w
and they had [ __ ] beach buckets of
root beer
it was a it was a bucket it was a pail
of root beer
and that's all i really remember about
the trip except for fields of corn
and this [ __ ] huge bucket of root
beer that we just sucked on the entire
time buddy i got news for you that's
trash
real [ __ ] trash dude the family trip
when you do
they had one of them in the shamany mall
that wasn't in the [ __ ] food court it
was like over by the wall or whatever
like
it's like it's going on here and a w
because i don't think that they still
even have
i don't even know what they were selling
was it only root beer no they were like
big
corn dogs i think they're big in canada
i think we've had canadian guests on
that say a w
is like a thing there i've seen one or
two in the philadelphia area but they
were just
a fast food chain that just didn't catch
on i don't know why but there's probably
like like like like there's no we're
seeing through that a and w
oh [ __ ] out it's a beverage like there's
nothing like there's not seven eleven or
seven up [ __ ] uh
i'll be over at the king with a couple
of burger buddies go so we were talking
about
we had a checkers by uh saint joe's prep
that we would [ __ ] hit up
shabby yeah check check out brought in
uh
gerard yeah i went to temple oh okay so
you know all about that checkers
the [ __ ] the greasiest of all fast
foods yeah there was a world star thing
that went live from
that went big that popped at that place
there was like a fight in it or
something like crazy that happened every
day i think they had it daily
part of the special yeah
pretty bananas
[Laughter]
[Music]
the five for five the five and a pound
deal
um growing up would you guys go to
outlet stores
oh my god uh ones but mostly
thrift shopping dude really i [ __ ]
hated and to this day wow hate
the smell of like thrift shops wait you
weren't going there because when i was
in high school
that was like grunge was big so we all
bought our [ __ ] at thrift stores you're
telling me your mom
honestly she was going in there just
like honestly trying to buy his clothes
like she was like uh i think that as
like i found out like way back
in school briefcases
but i found out way after the fact that
we were like that they were like we had
some poor ass years and my my family
just like hid it from me they just
didn't let me know
but uh that thrift store was a dead
giveaway yeah i don't know
what the [ __ ] my mom got really into
macklemore yeah
but uh like i i still like there was no
irony to it there was no
like uh uh like trying to find some like
classic old [ __ ]
it was just like this is the best we
could do was going to a thrift shop and
like
it still like bothers me to the day like
the smell inside of a thrift store so
that's disgusting
so you keep it all fresh oh i i like i
have to
like just because i i would hate my i
hate that smell and libraries just
do an elementary school library is tough
yeah just a disgusting ass
sleepy ass book cracking a book open and
just [ __ ]
old ass book disgusting no one's ever
read this book
oh i love it terrible but i think we
would go down to like the outlets in
like uh
like perryville where you're driving
like [ __ ] maryland to go to like the
hours like
outside right here dude everything's a
regular kind of it
never fit right the lunch was always the
big selling point on those journeys
oh yeah yeah well we're gonna stop at
crackle barrel for lunch you like that
right we're gonna hit a santa bone yo
cinnabons i think i could i would have
done anything for a cinnabon
from like [ __ ] 80 85 to [ __ ] 95.
yes i could have killed somebody once i
[ __ ] with them i think
who didn't [ __ ] think i've never met
somebody why not
what about we just never we were in
auntie anne's family i don't know
get me a [ __ ] brown sugar yes good
[ __ ] night
yeah that's a big [ __ ] screaming cold
coke
family that's a wrap i revisited the
outlets though uh like
a couple years like maybe like five or
six years ago
uh or actually it was before my car got
stolen uh in philly but uh
i got my my my car my tires got slashed
at the outlets and uh
i don't know why the [ __ ] someone would
go to the outlets and not slash somebody
because they're angry people it's not
good they're angry and they like save
them
but like that was the only time i've
ever got my what out iris
i think it was like it was the
perryville ones in but i think it was
like the nike i don't even know but it
was stopped at a specific outlet i used
to go to the [ __ ]
i used to like make it a couple of times
you had to go to the poll i thought i
was like hot [ __ ] i go to the polo well
i get a couple hundred bucks go to the
polo
outlet yes and buy a bunch of [ __ ]
shitty polos
we're at ac in atlantic city no the ac
ones are they're kind of nice they
say ain't too bad we've done shows down
there and i've went and just got close
at their outlets but these were in like
flemington new jersey or something
or uh franklin mills had a polo outlet
as well
you're taking your life in your hands at
franklin mills mall oh yeah that's
dangerous
that place was [ __ ] not great
franklin mills are also i was a big
foreman mills are you a big foreign
yes we never slumbed it that bad outlets
would be but
do burlington cofac i don't think i've
ever been in one no i have they go on
for it
yeah you get lost and there's a little
kid you hang on tight
yeah you get lost in a [ __ ]
windbreaker aisle like
you'll never see it again [ __ ]
frightening yeah it is just
i gotta i gotta i got one for the whole
table it's so it's it's kind of ha uh
holiday current times gotcha uh
when you get a card from a family member
be it like merry happy christmas
happy hanukkah whatever how long do you
keep it are you putting it on the
counter
real nice or you just straight into the
front i trash it right away right away
yeah i left mine i have like a stack on
the counter i was like i i said a week
was what i i was like let me just leave
these out for a week
to i don't know i don't even know what i
wanted to accomplish buy it these are
christmas cards
their pictures are on it it i'll keep it
yeah for like what happens or something
for a little bit but like if somebody
gives me a
like my aunt every year gives me a
[ __ ] like the money holder with 100
with a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're going to keep a money holder
you're not scratching yeah i
i put the hundo in the pocket and toss
it out the window on the boulevard good
night
but as a youth you guys never kept cards
you never because like
those that was a joy keeping a card and
then going through the stack of cars
being like did i leave did i forget it
20 in here
that was anything dude really hoping to
find a 20 in there
once or twice i would find old money i
don't know why i did that on my parents
house
in our coat in our coat closet in the
front every one every like few months
like clockwork like i'm like you know
when i got home from school no one was
home
i just go through the roads and [ __ ]
to find something but i do i do that in
the their pill cabinet
so does he doesn't do it here he doesn't
discriminate
i lost a 100 bill in 2012 in my mom's
house and i haven't stopped looking for
it
yeah i go home and i'm like these [ __ ]
are because i knew i left you yeah you
got pins and a couch
okay uh any of your family cars ever
have wood paneling
ooh no no they didn't we never were
lucky enough to have uh like any
uh the woodies you would have had the
minivan we had a minivan we had a couple
minivans we had the mercury voyager and
then we upgraded to a honda odyssey
we also had like a rose gray uh toyota
corolla from like 92 or something that
was a very trash car
yeah those are absolutely different them
in the camry but they last forever they
last forever ever
yeah and then the camry i wound up with
the camera after that and that's the one
i had from high school until
it got stolen it just got stolen in
philly i just like parked it wherever i
lived and how long ago was this
it's probably about uh a year before i
moved so about five years huh
so kept it pretty long yeah i kept it
for a long ass time what are you zipping
around in now
uh no car no car no sir guys subway
ubers
subway yeah subway and ubers nice
exclusively very cool
i'm a lift man myself
[Laughter]
it's a bad reflex it's like i'm
pavlovianly trained it's like
see you can grow a full beard you're
sure
anybody asking him questions he tightens
up oh yes
sir i apologize have you ever
called anybody mate or have you ever
said cheers instead of thank you when
someone handed you something oh
as an american no no bartender hands you
a glass of beer
thanks or cheers mate oh wow no right
i don't think i have but i i think at
some time i've like
admired people doing that where i'm like
oh i should add that to my pocket
i remember a guy did that to you i just
i know where the origin of this question
came from and it bothered him
for weeks we went to some bars cheers
mate
some bar in the east village to get
[ __ ] we were actually recorded an
episode of hard feelings
at that bar yeah and um and uh it was
like you know one of those like mixology
kind of bars in the east village and you
got like suspenders and [ __ ] like that
clearly american though and he hits us
with the mates and the cheers and mate
you're getting [ __ ] beat up oh big
time uh somebody hands you your citywide
special cheers mate
what are we in [ __ ] i like doing it over
there i've been over there and he makes
you feel like you're part of the gang
you know what i mean yeah cheers i do it
um but i can't do it you can't do it
here that's trash
yeah it is big time that'd be like a
going over there in a british you'd hit
you with a howdy
culture culture's not a costume
[Laughter]
you don't say that
[Laughter]
somebody's saying john in germany
the [ __ ] did you use jones
[Laughter]
i'll take two of those jaws ah the
john's are lovely this time of year
a couple of they knew about that they
would probably take that
that's a great word man it really is and
like when i go back i don't even realize
i say it it just like
slips back in yeah someone asked me one
time it's like you're from philly do you
say john
and i never i never even thought about i
don't like consciously say it like i'll
say it if it's the situation warrants
it's
like it's part of insult you're like
yeah
you're not gonna be like oh i'm gonna
say john now it's just like when you're
there and you hear it it just slips out
whom's john's are they says john balloon
[Laughter]
drawn is another philly word our buddy
reggie's
drawing drawing drawing and drawing
drawing
yeah this dude is drawing
man that accent yeah we tried to get to
the bottom of it dude i
man i have all these philly spots that i
probably did rap shows at that i don't
know if you guys ever did oh by the way
we got to talk about we did a show
together the three of us have done a
show together that's what i'm trying to
figure out
refresh my memory mad river maniac oh
[ __ ] there was probably about seven
people in the total
and i rapped it had to be something
special our buddy tom cassidy
fellow ran a show out there at mad river
and there was something this is how i i
found out about that he's
like yeah i got rhone he's going to come
out he's going to do it i'm like all
right and
it had to be sometime around christmas i
feel like
it was an office christmas party that we
got booked to do
and probably you were the headliner
probably and that poor [ __ ] christmas
party dude imagine me being the [ __ ]
headless
probably five there was probably five
bad comedians before you
we didn't warm them up at all man we
thought we were a hot [ __ ] back then
so did i we all did yeah dude but that
same man young
cringe probably the same year i hosted a
miss
new booty competition with bubba sparks
it was me and bubba sparks hosting the
host in the miss new booty competition
that's pretty big
and it was like i probably got paid more
for the miss new booty than for the
[ __ ]
sponsored by booty
think that barstool sports is saving
that
madness i knew because there was a big
thing i don't know you guys i know
i don't know it was dave or somebody i
would just see like mad mad river man
young's dope and i was like
that's crazy i don't even know it was
open i might have just let the cat out
of the bag early on that i'm not sure
but
i think that whether he has or is
planning on it i think that there's like
he has some kind of plan too you guys i
remember that he would be doing stuff
there over
you know when you guys went to philly
what you guys are doing with that is
pretty [ __ ]
amazing it's pretty crazy amazing shout
out to the [ __ ] bar still fun that's
unreal
and uh i think tim dillon posted a tweet
about it he's like
the fact that this isn't being covered
on the news is insane yeah which it is
[ __ ] completely insane
literally directly helping people like
right there on the [ __ ] spot
right they don't want to they don't want
to talk about that and like beyonce gave
out like
ten five like five thousand dollar
grants and it's like cnn like breaking
news
or something like that but i mean it is
what it is like there's people who have
made up their mind that they're not
gonna like something no matter what good
it does where it's like crazy you're
gonna waste your energy on those people
you know what i mean that's [ __ ] it's
a good outlook it's like 17 mil right
now
18. it was over 18 mil it's [ __ ]
ridiculous and he said penn just did but
donated a million
yeah they're over 18. send my tape in
huh yeah yeah
right they're throwing around [ __ ]
shots are you garbage all right
llc yeah i gotta pay toby
yeah i got a hot dog cart on street road
[ __ ]
all i need is like 12 bucks i'll be back
dude i have had a lot
of like my friends from home can you
help me out with this it's like dude
you're you [ __ ] like run a [ __ ]
pierogi business
that hasn't been open for eight years
like you're not doing anything with your
[ __ ] life
you're not just going to get the money
like this can they rebuild the vet
what's up
that jail up in the bottom of the event
by the way i have a piece of the event
that i want i forgot i want to bring in
that's like our prized possession i'm
still in my garage
the video is fully crying he's like i'm
finally gonna get a jacket that fits
yo what's up alprez i need to get
clothes for my friend he can't afford to
shop at dxl because it's too expensive
and he says the guys aren't really fat
guys that work there
and they intimidate him and there's
always a hot chick so you know if i
could get a couple of bucks to get him
some t-shirts that fit
that'd be dope man it was just dave on a
facetime
no call you got his number crying yeah
dave's crying
i just gotta get this bad guy so close
oh that would be great shooting if
there's enough they get enough money in
that [ __ ]
dude we're all gonna they're gonna run
out of [ __ ] needy businesses
eventually i love the fact that you're
derelict
yeah like i was thinking dude so many of
them it's like [ __ ] up how many of
them were like
handouts
i was up there i got a monster what's up
you know i'm on disability room i can't
even work
how am i going to make the parade you
got to put it my mom's name though
that's the weird thing or yeah some of
them are trying to like blackmail me
with it too they're like yo we gave this
money like
now can you like set up like some kind
of like meeting with me and dave
are you trying to bribe me through
charity what is going on i don't know if
you saw my eight bucks i did it
let me talk to the main guy at least let
me get a hoodie
that's beautiful but what what you guys
are doing over there is absolutely
unbelievable no it's good it's nice to
have like a good pr story come out about
bars too it's fantastic man
for once in a while but we did it but uh
to to go back to our our crossovers
though we have had a lot of crossovers
chris cotton was a big crossover yeah it
was cotton
yeah man he was shout out to cotton we
used to do he used to like host some
shows that i was doing
like like yeah like the fire or whatever
like the most
the shittiest [ __ ] venues on uh on
like giraffe fourth in gerard or
something
like that oh yeah i know that place yeah
then i was in like the [ __ ]
improv scene in in uh philly for a while
garbage why is it garbage no
i know why it's garbage why were you
involved in it because
somebody gave me an occupation
there were more people we have more
people on stage than in the audience
like every single time as a stand-up
comedian that's happened to me
[Laughter]
where you're coming from i remember
looking at one guy being like dude just
go home
nobody wants it just go home it was like
my family members that were coming
wait so we were doing yeah we like
joined a team called like
it was like i took like a class at like
the adrian or some [ __ ] like that was
this po
is this after the rap battling this was
like i was doing rap battles and i was
like uh
keeping it from the improv team and like
that my like coach like called me over
he's like is this is this you like are
you
doing this because like i was
embarrassed about the improv for the
rest of you
yeah yeah that's like that's like a
weird like room like something i would
see on netflix he tried to hide
yeah i was like sir i was like sneaky
about it and uh
like neither one helped the other but it
was mostly so we could just like
i i like a new group of friends to drink
with we were like called
like we wanted to be called like fart
daddy or something like that and then
like we had so it was like just a
terrible improv
the worst the worst names i've never
heard
and we changed it to the sardines
because we just would do it at
american sardine bar in like uh wherever
the [ __ ] that is in philly
uh so we i did it for like three years
and it was like i'd like to break up
with the team to move to new york
it was i was not good at it i'll be
honest with you i i was i was bad at it
and it's a
tough scene but that's a trash story
yeah
have you ever had to break up with your
improv team because they were like they
were like dude this guy's not showing up
i was getting like passive aggressive
texts from my hair brought to em i was
like you're not even
a man dude there is no form of comedy
lower than an improv
it was so bad it makes my skin crawl to
just like
think about [ __ ] improv as like an
art
i mean it was i guess i don't i don't
even know what it's done when it's done
real i've seen it
really well it's like as a comedian with
a comedian brain i'm like holy [ __ ]
this is like next level comedy the way
they're thinking and enjoying everything
but when it's bad i guess what they're
not an ambush show at a bar in philly
when it's bad it's [ __ ] good it was
not good
but i even go back and watch whose line
is it anyway and i'm like oh man like
i used to love it and i don't want to go
back and ruin it because to me they were
the
dude ryan was the funniest guy in the
world
and now that i know how comedy works i
don't want to ruin it right exactly
because you learn something about how it
works and then you look back and it's
like
and it also like to me improv kind of
like got me off of comedy
or like kind of threw my scent off a
little bit because like i would get
scolded for like
going blue and they're like we don't do
that here and i would like have like a
off-color joke or something and they
like i don't know if it's just pushing
me to be better which i
resented but but like i would try
i wanted to tell some dirty jokes and
they like ushered me away from that
that's not that's not their vibe at all
at all our buddy our buddy reggie was at
uc our buddy reggie conquest was at ucb
and we went to his graduation show and
he [ __ ] killed like
murdered and we were like holy [ __ ] and
then afterwards they were yelling at him
like you can't just go for laughs all
the time we're like that's what comedy
is you're [ __ ]
talking about what are we doing like you
have to build the scene i'm like reggie
[ __ ] beat it with these nerds dude
after my first show i got like called
over by my team for doing like an
indian accent and they sat me down but
there was an indian couple in the crowd
like an older couple and they were dying
that was like the funniest thing to them
but i got like sat down because
i guess um that's so [ __ ] up
yeah i love you boys never tried improv
we did one when we first i never did
when the first year not a [ __ ]
the first year i was up here i would do
the open mics just for
just for like you can't get stage time
when you move up here the exercise
yeah and yeah similar similar situation
i saw some great ones like at the
at the ucb used to do an open mic yeah
yeah and like an open mic improv but
they would have some team like close it
out or whatever
most of them were trash but they had
this one from la and they [ __ ]
they were like just in perfect sync just
killing they were great
yeah you know it's like lacrosse you
watch [ __ ] shitty you know lacrosse
you're like or hockey or something like
that
when it's done well it's unbelievable
but like watching pee wee hockey is like
probably the
unwatchable especially when some 25 year
old girl from ithaca
is [ __ ] giving you [ __ ] no one's ever
told
her no one's ever told her you stink no
kidding why [ __ ] it
it was the perfect town
improv
what are you doing
parents paying for everything i'm on
like one hour sleep [ __ ]
have you ever taken a [ __ ] on an
airplane uh
yeah definitely kevin you too yeah i got
no problem with that
yeah i don't prefer it but you know a
long flight
over two hours three hours and you get
jammed up
do what you gotta do i used to have poop
like uh stage fright of like even being
in like
the same like houses a bunch of people
pooping but then i lived down the shore
for an entire summer with 12
people in one bathroom and like eight of
them were girls so i was like
i'm gonna have to just poop in front of
these people i have to come to grips
with it
that's as a fat guy there's nothing
worse yeah there's no
[Laughter]
i would never [ __ ] on a plane why at the
size i am because it's just
that's not i've already asked for the
seat belt extender you know what i mean
you have a bathroom extension right now
we have a double-wide bathroom can we
knock this wall down between these two
or
you're the only guy i know that could
clog an airplane
[Laughter]
yeah i would not be scared plus i don't
know if i'd be able to get back there
and take care of business with how tight
it is yeah yeah it's better for
everybody on the plane that you don't
you don't even i hold out my buddy
glenny balls has a theory that like
uh fat guys are unfairly like people
will attach a smell to a fat guy
unfairly and it's just like they assumed
that the fat guy farted they assumed
that the fat guys were like
if the bathroom stinks after someone
pooped in the last half hour they're
like
why did you do this 100 i understand
do you think that's unfairly do you
think that
yeah i think it's discriminatory because
sometimes it wasn't me
sometimes but you know the number of
times it is
do people yeah does everybody emit smell
i think everyone admits smelled it the
same way i think even a skinny ass dude
faster metabolism
they're probably cooking up stinky ears
that's what you do is always happening i
had this one good looking buddy shout
out to my buddy nate brubaker thought he
was going to say kevin ryan
in college real good-looking dude in
shape he
it was always his thing to when it was a
crowded party he would he would rip a
fart
and like just die laughing about it and
anytime he would do it next to me
i would like get mad at him like what
the [ __ ] dude like these chicks you're
gonna come back
you were eating a meatball parm at the
time
what the [ __ ] i have to put away
holsters the park it's got too man
save these for later a reheated farm is
a reheated farm's terrible
uh growing up were you a sh i got a
two-part question were you shoes on it
on or off in the household
on there was never i've never even been
uh she was on in the household
i never even until like the last i think
it was like in
i was in like toronto for something when
i even was introduced to the concept of
taking shoes off in the house
oh we were [ __ ] that's a dirtbag
thing right now i like that we've got to
go to another country to find nice
people
you guys do this because we were going
to be canadian wait i'm surprised no
friends
moms on the main line would make you
take your shoes off i'm trying to
remember a couple of jewish moms in
there somewhere i don't really i don't
no we definitely didn't know when to do
it friends
no i went to a catholic grade school so
i i honestly didn't have until i went
went to like college i didn't have like
a lot of jewish friends
that uh that that would have any kind of
rules like that i'm trying to remember i
don't know maybe i was just like
we did it if we had new we got new
carpet like once or twice growing up for
like so for a week in the 80s for a
couple i think i made that joke already
like 20 episodes ago
um and then would you put your feet on
the coffee table if you're watching tv
feed up on the table
yeah we just had to actually get a new
coffee table because like the lean
yeah like my dad's house to lean it was
like too creaky yeah like people were
putting their [ __ ] off
that's a trash move i was doing that
this weekend i was like oh i am garbage
yeah i put the feet up on the in and the
new the new coffee table is beautiful
the the structural integrity
is here it's got 15 years left in that
thing that was where the line drew for
us
we were allowed to have our shoes on
house but you couldn't put your shoes on
the coffee table but no shoes on would
you put your feet up on the coffee
oh yeah yeah yeah you do that now have
at it oh yeah what do you mean yeah put
my nuts on the coffee
drag those things around i got told by
the conductor on the metro north railway
to take my shoes off the seat
today yeah that's trash shut up that's
trashy and did you like fake put them
down and then they went past you put
them back up yeah
[ __ ] renegade then wrote a song about
it yeah skater died
and i spray painted his face man i ran i
floated away from the cops
jumped in the hudson um can you say with
a hundred percent certainty
that every member of your nuclear family
mom dad sister
has had eggs benedict before oh
no my my my uh like my mom
and sister like don't eat vegetables
they're like children
they like i can't i can't pay
that's a bad look because there are no
vegetables involved
that's pretty [ __ ] trashy right there
i think he was saying my soft pretzel
eating friend
nah nah we don't take vitamins yeah does
it grow old yeah
i ain't no no [ __ ] french eggs [ __ ]
you call me fat
but no it was more to uh illustrate that
they have the the palettes of children
like they're not gonna try some new or
different [ __ ]
uh have you had eggs benedict i have had
a different types of benedicts
have you uh have you ever you have a
benedict on you right now
yeah i bought a a duffel um i've never
had
you ever had caviar no never had caviar
you
of course where are you getting caviar i
just saw because somebody posted in the
facebook group that they sell it at
walmart apparently
oh really for like 4.99 you can get
caviar
everyone's the illusion that's the
caviar car security system
and if our listeners are [ __ ] posting
multiple guys like i love that [ __ ] so
it's got to be cheap
i'm sure our listeners are dirt balls
i'm sure you have had caviar do you eat
sushi
oh yeah i guess so the little orange
ones that would count as caviar i guess
so yeah i don't like that i've never had
the black
i had that that's not caviar i had the
black ones once at nobu
which i went recently that's a very very
special occasion
the [ __ ] are you doing it was a birthday
spin in that patreon
yeah we're still broke it was a one-time
this guy's going to hawaii he's got no
boo
no he was picking up a ship that's
busting tables i was pretending to be a
waiter to get some leftovers
uber eats folks done with that i had it
there it's awesome
how old were you the first time you had
lobster
uh like [ __ ] 28 yeah i had it like i
think two years ago penn state maine
[Laughter]
yeah and i did not know lobster i was
disgusted by it
really i think that i think lobsters
like lobster
is a trash thing to eat like i don't
know how because of the bottom feeder
thing
that and like what other food do you put
like
as you're eating something you put it on
the carcass of it like you bite off some
of the lobster and then you put it down
to rest on its own carcass
like imagine that with like a chicken
like the whole dead chicken body
you like rip off the breast and then
like rest the rest of the breast on top
with a couple of his friends watching in
a tank
down the hallway yeah that's [ __ ]
actually yeah
yeah i get it um how old were you when
you got your passport
uh i think i had a passport as
as a youth okay yeah i went to belgium
one time on a
as a youth ah it's not bad grandmother
i've seen all right
belgian family okay that's pretty good
what grocery store did your parents go
to growing up
acme and jennardi charlie
gennard's couple of hometown philly
faves right there
you can't go wrong with either of those
yeah acme was like
for whatever and then gennardi's you get
all of the things like if you really
need or
bj's we were a bj family okay we belong
to the club
bj's yes sir what's the ruling on that i
feel that's pretty trashy oh big time
right
big time anytime you're buying like
anything yeah 85
gatorades you're buying 90 gallons of
pickles
what makes those trashy and has the
stigma of being trashy is the fact that
only one or two people you knew had a
membership
so what would happen was is that you
would have other family members like
like listen aunt rose going over to bj's
she's got the
card so we're gonna go with her to get
some stuff yeah there's nine different
there's nine different families going
yeah get a palette of applesauce
or my parents would tell me not to eat
beforehand because we're gonna have
samples
we're gonna go around [ __ ] trash it
was like six
six different sets um did you drink milk
with dinner growing up
uh yeah i think i think i had a lot of
milk as a youth i think my parents were
pumping milk
that's [ __ ] weird skim milk family
too
that's trash wow i think we're really
[ __ ] getting to it here it's like a
wheat bread skim milk family like my
family strowman's wheat i think so
yeah my parents like it sounds like a
fun household yeah they thought it was
disgusting jesus i was like throwing out
my lunch when i got to school i would
just not eat lunch because it was like
disgusting
old ass [ __ ] wheat peanut butter and
jelly it wasn't great but my parents
thought it was healthy i guess i don't
know
still sure it was the 90s it was the 80s
and 90s it was wide open man yeah it
really was
uh do you put chips on a sandwich
i think i might have saw that on twitter
now that i say that out loud that i was
putting chips on this yeah i think
that's how
somebody tagged us in it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a must dude
must dude i'll put anything on a [ __ ]
sandwich i'll put goldfish crackers on a
sandwich
pretzels i'm about to open your eyes to
some [ __ ]
lay it on me uh reese's puffs
on a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
wow pour the reese's puffs on the peanut
butter it
sticks and then you have a little crunch
to your peanut butter and jelly sandwich
but it's already a peanut buttery flavor
that's pretty good i do that with
pretzels already put pretzels on a beer
pretzel hers pretzels
on an amoroso roll thread i do the
inverse of that any cereal i'm eating
i'd do a little scoop of peanut butter
on the side
[Music]
really yeah dude game changer try it
it's unbelievable it's like a dirtbag
acai bowl
holy [ __ ] big man's throwing heat this
week folks
it can't be stopped that's tragic he's
going to crash the peanut butter
he looked at me i saw the glen of the
sniper swing
all he said these red dots end up on
toby's head how does it even work do you
like
uh nurse the peanut butter or fat scoop
of peanut butter on the side
you know grab a little little scoop of
peanut butter a little scoop of cereal
it's [ __ ] tasty treat bro yeah a
little back and forth
elevates it i don't know all right very
nice sounds bananas um i just also
like throwing some bananas in there with
the peanut butter oh i love bananas in
my cereal come on
get out of here not for me why not for
me i'm not trying to have any any type
of fruit in my series
and honey nut cheerios oh that was a
folding classic
[Laughter]
what you got to do is you get the
reese's cups the guy's like cheers
how do you live now you go who does the
shopping at your place are you guys
doing like trader joe's whole foods
yeah there's like uh yeah something
close something like that something real
fancy
i'm like uh if i shop i'm buying like i
i can make like two things i can like
boil like a beautoni uh ravioli
or like i'll make corned beef hash you
tony ravioli
we think we're real classy with those
fresh ravioli
oh i'm gonna cook tonight here yeah
meanwhile they've been sitting on the
shelf for like 15.
we get those things we're [ __ ] hey
how you doing we're [ __ ] living it up
right and that and uh corned beef hash
which i guess the irish side i mean yeah
corned beef house
out of a cake and a can of hash yeah i
was going to say with eggs right
yes sir yes sir yeah [ __ ] on the shingle
isn't that what it is is that what it is
no no that's cream chips
corn chippy yeah yeah right right
what's beef what's whack though what's
beef on whack i feel like that might be
some buffalo [ __ ] sounds like beef
does it always wrap with your own jesus
christ if i had to guess uh yo mtv raps
classic episode beef on whack
that's the vh1 spin-off of this uh mtv
raps
i don't know what that is i don't know
how did you guys go into the rap battle
bro
but i heard reigns playing
i got a call we got a couple from the
patreon because as you know when you
join the patreon we will ask all your we
will ask one of your questions because
so many people submit [ __ ] questions
that we just can't there's too many we
can't get enough of them
so when you get to when you join patreon
we'll read your question this is from
uh brady which i'm assuming for sure do
you know anybody that got a dui before
the age of 21
i know something
i know someone uh that's uh i guess i
guess we all know him
he's a great guy he's okay the uh
first offenders program has uh gone
through its ten years and
that's actually been scrubbed from his
record good for him he's
he's good to go yeah good good good for
that gentleman
excellent yes um you no
dui never know anybody that had one
anybody in your family have them
no you got a couple of derelicts
immediate family no but yeah well
somebody
in our extended family might i might
have caught a couple deweys
i've been on the yeah i've been in the
driver's seat for one i've been in the
passenger seat for somebody else's top
for the other
yeah pull it the sur thing
is a cheat code for duis like i've got
uh we've gotten out of [ __ ]
because of like good sir etiquette
taking the [ __ ] uh keys out of the
ignition put him on the thing putting
your hands on just
like respect to the point of disrespect
and then they'll let your ass go that's
what they want
shout out to the philly pd we were going
down it was something it was actually
something
something you don't hear often it was a
rest cut down it was a rap event or
something it was i was in college maybe
we were driving down
we were on gerard avenue and we're
drinking in the car i got a case of beer
and i might have told this and
the cop catches me drinking i didn't see
him i look left i look right i don't see
him you know i'm in the back seat
not driving driver was totally not
drinking either gonna go on record there
and uh
so i like bottoms up to finish the
bottle and the cop goes i caught you and
i'm like i drop it between my feet and i
like pull my hands up like i'm just
hanging out you know
no bottles of beer here he's like i
caught you man i'm like [ __ ]
he goes just dump it out and i'm like oh
thank god i'm like it's empty man i
swear to god it's empty and then he goes
uh
because i'm just [ __ ] with you keep
drinking it i'm like all right man see
ya and then he blew the red light
later he sent you on your way yeah he
goes the driver's not drinking izzy and
we're like no
he's like i'll take your word for it
have a good night jesus christ
a bigger fish to fry yeah especially
like third in gerard
a similar thing happened in uh it was
like plymouth white marsh area but we
were smoking dope in the car we were
smoking a blunt in the car and the cop
pulled us over and
he like he saw us he was starting to
arrest us but the dude in the back seat
was like
like i drink with you it's like we know
each other like i've been at the same
party as you and the guy like
threw the ticket out and just like had
us on our way like it was like
the suburbs they were going to not only
like write us up they were going to
arrest
yeah but since he the guy knew they knew
the cop a little bit personally
yeah drinking with the cops
this guy's got it coming and going uh
all right this is from cameron harris i
think we've talked about this
will you talk uh use speakerphone in
public
oh god ah it's [ __ ] do you
depends not like in front of people but
you do talk to text which is [ __ ]
trashy it's the worst are you
no are you and you're just yelling at
your phone are you talking to me
my mom does that [ __ ] too and she'll do
it in like the middle of like
an important conversation it's like text
messaging is meant to be discreet yeah
like you would do it easily with your
thumb and she'll like just start talking
dead into her phone while we're having
like we're talking about something
serious and she'll just come
here tommy's cheating on nancy you're
like yo what the [ __ ]
why are you bringing this up the ground
turkey instead of the ground beef
that's improv chops right there folks
face timing in public is awesome
uh animalistic what if you're okay what
if you're away from people
if you walk away from people i think
that there's something if you're taking
care that's a courtesy that's a courtesy
acknowledgement of like hey what i'm
about to do isn't you know socially
because on vacation we went we saw the
sunrise every morning and we'd always
face time with our parents now there was
people like in the general area
but i mean i wasn't like screaming like
i'm on the bus or anything i think if
you have something to show
i think that it's okay but if you just
want to look at somebody's face
you ever see people walking down the
street facetiming on speakerphone and
not even
looking at like no one's making eye
contact yeah i'm not doing that i'm not
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's gotta be like smoker's
rules like 15 feet from the door
sure take a step off the curb get away
from the gym excuse yourself yeah you
got to excuse yourself
um all right we got to wrap up we've
been pushing together um all right this
is from chris one more um
is it trashy to have uh magnets from
destinations that you've personally
never been to
like if someone has a home run of a
question dude
if someone went to paris and brings you
back a magnet
yeah dude that is [ __ ] true at least
got to put on the side of the fridge so
you're not misrepresenting yourself
you've been at disney world uh well not
exactly i just have the snow globe
because i like shot glasses from cancun
i gotta ever been a [ __ ] gang
mardi gras beads and [ __ ] oh that's
great yeah that's trash
that's right my last thing that i'll
submit for me being uh trash
for me being closing arguments is that
uh recently i was walking back to my
house
and uh i saw a guy selling out of the
back of his convertible
uh a sleeve of deodorants uh uh
travel deodorants and uh there were
women's deodorants but i stopped and i
bought a sleeve from
this guy and uh he he after i bought
them he said it was secret exactly and
he's not my secret he said are you on
your way to the halfway house too
i was like this makes me feel pretty
garbage and so i was like
rifling through before i came on and i
was like that's my most garbage thing
i want to bring something to the table
buying sleeves of travel women's
deodorant while getting mistaken for
being on my way to the halfway house
that's how i want to be seen by you guys
you cut me in for 20 i could be on my
way anywhere
what kind of convertible uh like i think
it was like a mazda or something
like that nothing nice he's in a miata
well i got news for you
um after careful deliberation
i think uh you can rest easy and know my
friend that you are
100 yeah that's pretty trash
thank you so much that that means the
most to me with a nice education and
some good test scores that's about it
yeah
putting lipstick on a pig dude yeah yeah
that's okay
the 14 30 you know but i thought the
family would
would save you but the coffee table
story the drive to iowa
the
yeah and you on your own i mean that
would be the only thing that would pull
you out of the fire
is your your father's princeton diploma
yeah but i need to put a i need a plaque
from you guys that i could put next to
that
diploma from him on the wall you guys
need to be giving out certificates
we will get those certificates that is a
fire identity certified garbage
buddy thank you so much thank you guys
you want the folks out there to know hit
them with it
no sir just uh for them to to get on
your guys patreon and keep on supporting
what you guys are doing because
i love it i'm a fan of what you guys are
doing thank you buddy keep it up keep it
up
appreciate that we're a big fan of yours
kippy what do you got also for the
listener foley really did send me a text
of get the ground turkey
instead of the ground i commit to a bet
they don't teach it
at the art and today guys thank you so
much for listening as always please make
sure you review subscribe on itunes
we're in the top 200 we [ __ ]
appreciate that we were number 28 at one
point
fell a little bit no big deal also check
out uh
99 and a half right now by the skin of
our bowls
um full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well those
numbers are [ __ ] through the roof we
appreciate that and then patreon.com
sign up for bonus content help us keep
the [ __ ] lights on thank you so much
peace